alright let's talk about the different
task queues and start off with the push
queue which is the most common one the
execution of push queues are managed by
App Engine itself
this means that App Engine has worker
threads that scan these queues and pick
up tasks these threads then call a URL
that you have specified when you insert
the tasks in the queue this means that
the execution is broken out from the
HTTP request/response flow since App
Engine provide the threads to execute
the tasks but the code used to process
each task is still provided by you since
you provide the URL that the worker
threads call the best of two worlds a
generic execution methodology that works
with code that you write so the worker
thread picks up task by task and calls
your URL for each of them and this
behavior continues for all the tasks in
the queue until the queue is empty
by default the maximum execution
duration for a task is 10 minutes it is
of course up to you when you develop the
application to split up the work into
tasks that can be completed within this
time for example a hundred mails each
there are many different configuration
options for queues in the following
screen we will look at some of them
first to note is the queues are defined
in a queue configuration file when you
do development all queues have a queue
name for all applications
happened in order to provides the
default queue with the name default this
queue can be used without adding
anything to the queue configuration file
but you may want to change its default
options in which case you need to define
it in the file
other things you can configure are the
performance parameters such as the rate
of processing the maximum rate in case
of traffic Peaks the bucket size and the
maximum number of concurrent tasks that
can be executed there are also a lot of
parameter surrounding error management
so now we've talked about how to define
a queue let's finish this part by
looking at how to create a task and
assign it to a queue for execution the
first thing you do is get the queue by
the queue name then you create the task
and set options such as the task name
the URL to process the task and other
parameters such as performance and retry
options and finally you add the task to
the queue for execute
finally it is important that you protect
the URL so only administrators can
access them through the permission
settings
you don't want external users to be able
to execute your task logic should they
get a hold of these URLs that was a lot
of theory but that's it for now now the
time has come for you to do some work
because we have an exercise coming up
where you will use push cues
good luck